[موسيقى]
تتواصل هجمات الجيش السوري الحر على
المقرات الامنيه والعسكريه للنظام السوري
واخر تلك الهجمات سيطره لواء الفرقان على
مقر فرع الامن العسكري في دير الزور الله
اك الله
[موسيقى]
اك
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في عنوانين رئيسيين
لماذا يستهدف الجيش السوري الحر المقرات
الامنيه والعسكريه تحديدا وما هي عوامل
نجاح المعارضه المسلحه في الهجمات التي
شنتها
[موسيقى]
مؤخرا لعل سيطره الجيش السوري الحر على
مقر فرع الامن العسكري في دير الزور
الحلقه الاح حدث في سلسله هجمات الجيش
الحر التي استهدفت المقرات الامنيه
والعسكريه للنظام السوري في مناطق مختلفه
لا سما في الشرق والشمال وتؤكد مصادر
الجيش الحر نجاحها في تطبيق استراتيجيه
استهداف المقرات الامنيه كضه استباقيه قبل
استخدام هذه المقرات من قبل نظام ضد الجيش
الحر او ضد المدنيين لكن على الجانب الاخر
لا تتحدث المصادر الرسميه السوريه كثيرا
عن هذه العمليات سلبا او
ايجاب دير الزور 39212 سقوط مقر الامن
العسكري في دير الزور في يدي الجيش السوري
الحر يعتبر الى حد كبير نتيجه طبيعيه
لحصار يومين كاملين دون وصول امدادات
لنجدته ولعل هذا التطور الميداني الذي
حققه لواء الفرقان التابع للمجلس العسكري
يشكل مع تطورات اخرى توالت في الايام
والاسابيع الماضيه من ع طفا في مسار
الثوره السوريه والحرب الطاحنه في البلاد
منذ عام
ونصف مقر الامن العسكري في اي مدينه سوريه
مازال النظام يسيطر عليها يكتسي اهميه
بالغه وان يكون ذلك المقر في عاصمه محافظه
حدوديه كدير الزور فهذا مما يزيده اهميه
استراتيجيه سواء بالنسبه للقوات الحكوميه
او للثوار غير ان هناك من يرى ان النظام
قد لا يكترث كثيرا لسيطره مناوئيه على هذا
الموقع او ذاك لشده تركيزه على دمشق لان
خساره اي نظام لعاصمه حكمه غالبا ما تكون
مؤشرا قويا على انهياره اسقاط الطائرات
المقاتله وضرب المطارات العسكريه كما حدث
في تفتناز وابو ظهور وفي منج اكثر من مره
مما يدعم القول ان الجيش السوري الحر يحقق
تقدما متسارعا ويعزز وجوده في مناطق
مختلفه من البلاد ففي محافظه دير الزور
نفسها ولكن في مدينه البوكمال على مرمى
حجر من الحدود مع العراق كان الثوار قد
اعلنوا قبل ايام سيطرتهم على مقار فروع
الامن العسكري والامن السياسي وحزب البعث
الحاكم اما حلب ثانيه كبرى المدن السوريه
وحاضره الشمال الرئيسيه فان اجزاء واسعه
منها باتت تحت سيطره الجيش الحر الذي
استولى فيها على ارتال عسكريه بكامل عدتها
وعتادها كما يقول الثوار انهم يغنم
الدبابات والاسلحه والذخيره كلما اغاروا
على قوات النظام ومن ذلك سيطرتهم على
كتيبه صواريخ في الغوطه الشرقيه وعلى
ناقله جند وصواريخ ومعدات اخرى في بلده
حران في ريف دمشق الحديث عن التطورات
الميدانيه الاخيره لا يكتمل دون التوقف
عند تمكن الثوار السوريين من الوصول الى
مقر قياده الاركان في قلب العاصمه ومن
قبلها الى مقر مكتب الامن الوطني حيث قتل
وزير الدفاع داوود راجحه وعدد من كبار
المسؤولين ولمناقشة
لينا عبر سكايب من البو كمل في دير الزور
محمد العران القائد الميداني في كتيبه
الله اكبر التابعه للجيش السوري الحر ومن
عمان اللواء الدكتور فائز الدويري الخبير
في الشؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه ومن
دمشق على الهاتف شريف شحاده الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي محمد العران القائد
الميداني في كتيبه الله اكبر واضح ان
الجيش الحر قد سطر له استراتيجيه في
المرحله القادمه كما قال مصطفى الشيخ
قائد المجلس العسكري في الجيش ووضع لذلك
استراتيجيه لضرب اهداف امنيه ومقرات
عسكريه ولكن انتم في دير الزور وكنتم احدث
طبعا العمليات التي قمتم بها في دير الزور
هي استهداف مقر الامن العسكري كيف نجحتم
انتم في هذه العمليه ولماذا اصلا اخترتم
هذا
الهدف
رج ان اصابات
تد
وكليب وكل
الاعتقالات من مفارز الامنيه ومفارز الامن
العسكري في دور السيطره عليها في دير
الزور نعم كيف نجحتم في في تنفيذ هذه
العمليه والسيطره على هذا
الفرع محمد
العران
نعم
بالحصار
كيف الحصار الحصار حصار المزه لعده
ايام
اهت طيب محمد عران للاسف الصوت لا يصلني
بشكل واضح سن نحاول العوده لاتصال بكامره
اخرى ضيفنا
في في عمان الدكتور فايز الدويري الخبير
في الشؤون العسكريه دكتور فايز من ناحيه
استراتيجيه وتكتيك والعمليه ايضا كيف نفهم
استهداف هذه المقرات الامنيه والعسكريه
وايضا قدره الجيش السوري الحر على تنفيذ
هذه الاستراتيجيه والوصول الى الاهداف
المسطره
لها مساء الخير اخ عبد الصمد لكم مشاهدي
الجزيره مساء الخير لا يمكن ان ناخذ ما
جرى في دير الزور بمعزل عنما جرى خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه على الجغرافيا السوريه
كامله هناك تصعيد خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
والايام الماضيه من من طرفي الصراع الجيش
الحر و وكتائب النظام او قوات النظام ولكل
دلالاته الاستراتيجيه الايجابيه والسلبيه
لو تحدثنا في البدايه عن التصعيد العسكري
من قبل قوات النظام هذا التصعيد تمثل في
عده جوانب الجانب الاول الاستخدام المفرط
وتزايد استخدام الطائرات المقات
والعموديه الجانب
الاخر استخدام مكثف للاسلحه الثقيله ومن
مديات ومن
مديات بعيده البعد الثالث تمثل في الاضرار
في البيئه السوريه بما شمل بما قام به من
عمليات احراق للغابات في المناطق الشماليه
وفي مناطق ادلب واللاذقية
وسائل هذا يعود الى عده اسباب السبب الاول
يتمثل في محدوديه القوات المتاحه للنظام
لاستخدامها الجيش السوري يمتلك نظريا قوات
فائض قوه ولكنه عمليا لا يمتلكها لديه 15
فرقه وما يستخدمه تقريبا اربعه فرق بسبب
عدم الثقه بهذه القوات والشك في درجه
ولائها النقطه الاخرى تتمثل
في ضعف الجيش السوري بصوره عامه في اجراء
عمليات الصيان اللازمه حيث بدا في الفتره
الاخيره يصلح بعض الاليات التي تتعطل من
اليات اخرى النقطه الثالثه ضعف او عدم
سيطرته على طرق الامداد خاصه في المنطقه
الواقعه ما بين اللاذقيه وجسر الشغور ادلب
اريحا فهذه المنطقه تمثل عقده مواصلات
وشريان حيوي لامداد القوات ولكنها اصبحت
جزئيا خارج السيطره هذه الامور كلها
مجتمعه ادت الى التصعيد باستخدام قوه
النار عن بعد واستخدام القوه الجويه هذا
الاستخدام المفرط هو ياتي ضمن نظريه ما
يعرف باستراتيجيه بوتن في جروزني تنفيذ
سياسه الارض المحروقه تدمير قتل البشر
وتدمير الحجر وقطع الشجر دكتور نريد ان
نعود في المرحله القادمه في حديثنا في هذه
الحلقه عن استهداف المقرات الامنيه
والعسكريه تحديدا نريد ان ان نحصر الحوار
والنقاش حول هذه النقطه بالذات وهنا اسال
شريف شحاده الكاتب والمحلل السياسي شريف
شحاده اذا كان نظام يقول في كثير من
المناسبات رغم كل ما يجري فانه يسيطر على
الوضع كي فنفهم ان تستطيع المعارضه
المسلحه الجيش الحر او الثوار الوصول الى
مقرات امنيه الى عقر دار هذه القوات
النظاميه وتشن فيها جمات بل وتسيطر على
عليها او على اجزاء
منها اولا مساء الخير اخ عبد الصمد ومساء
الخير للساده المشاهدين حقيقه لا توصف
الامور على هذا الشكل على الاطلاق اولا
سوريا تخوض حرب معلنه و واضحه واعتقد ان
القدرات السوريه حقيقه تبرز يوما بعد يوم
في واجه هذه المجموعات المسلحه واعتقد
ايضا ان الكلام عن انهم يستطيعون ان
يسيطروا على هذا على هذه المنطقه او تلك
المنطقه وه الموقع هو كلام يعني حقيقه
تثبته الايام ان لا صحه له قد يقومون ببعض
التفجيرات انا اعترف بذلك هذه التفجيرات
تحدث في كل دول العالم في مقار عسكريه في
مقار مدنيه هذا امر طبيعي تخوط حرب استاذ
شريف حاده عذرا المقاطعه عذرا لمقاطعه فقد
اذكرك ببعض المعلومات يعني السيطره على
مقر الامن فرع الامن العسكري في دير الزور
مثلا في مناطقه اخرى نفس الشيء واستهداف
اسمح لي استهداف مطار ابو الظهور وتدمير
عدد من الطائرات الرابض في المطار وتدمير
عدد ايضا والحصول على عدد من الاسلحه
واستهداف مطار المزه وايضا مطار كوريس
ومطار منج وتفتناز وغير ذلك تفضل يعني اذا
اردت ان لا اعطيك معلومات يعني اكتفي بهذا
الحديث رجعا دعني اوضح الصوره حتى يفهم
الساده المشاهدين ما القصد قد يستطيع اي
قد تستطيع اي مجموعه زرع عبوه او مهاجمه
اي مطار او اي موقع عسكري هذا امر طبيعي
لكن السؤال المنطق وفي العلم العسكري من
يقول انني مسيطر يجب عليه في الحد الادنى
ان يبقى في هذا المكان لمده ثلاثه اشهر
هذا اولا ثانيا تحدثتم انتم عن انهم
اطلقوا ايه او سيطروا على مطار المزي
العسكري اولا هذا هو مطار عسكري موجود
شاهد عيان على الارض السوريه وفي منطقه
قريبه من دمشق لم يسيطروا عليه وانا اقول
لك حاولوا اطلاق بعض القذائف الار بيجي من
مسافات بعيده لكنهم حتى في في في موضوع
القاذفات الار بي جي لم يستطيعوا الوصول
اليها انا اقول لك قد يستطيعون الاستلاء
على سياره على مدرعه على عربي وهي ذي حرب
نقوم بها نحن في مواجهه هذه العصابات لكن
دعني اقول لك حتى الفرع الامن العسكري
الذي تتحدث عنه في دير الزور انا اعرف دير
الزور واعرف هذه المناطق التي يتحدثون
عليها هناك قام الجيش العربي السوري
بتفريغ هو بنفسه بتفريغ بعض الاماكن
العسكريه ونقله الى اماكن عسكريه اكثر
امنا واكثر حيويه له وبالتالي اصبحت هناك
امكنه فارغه نعم هي فرع للامن العسكري
ولكن كما نقول سابقا نعم هناك وانت تعلم
انه هناك في دير الزور اكثر من خمسه فروع
او سته فروع امن يكون احداها قد تم تفريغه
ونقل الى مكان اخر ثم يقولون لك انا سيطرت
تحدثوا عن سيطره في دمشق لم نجدها تحدثوا
عن سيطره في دمشق ولم نجدها تحدثوا عن
سيطره في حمص في حلب ولم نجدها من يريد ان
يسيطر عليه ان يجلس في المكان في الحد
الادنى شهر حتى نقول انه سيطر هذه
العمليات انا اقول لك تجري في كل دول
العالم وسوريا تخوض حربا في مواجهه هذه
المجموعات المسلحه وانا اقول لك ن بعد
استشهاد القياده العسكريه السابقه هناك
قياده عسكريه الان اصبحت واضحه المعالم
وهناك قياده امنيه صارمه ولديها مفهوم عن
ما يحصل في سوريا ورسمت خريطه متكامله
واضحه عن سوريا باكملها في مواجهه كل ما
يحدث لذلك انا اقول لك العمل العسكري منذ
استشهاد الضباط الاربعه الى الان تحدث
وتطور وعرفت اليه العمل بالنسبه للمجموعات
المسلحه وانا اقول لك هذه التفجيرات التي
نراها وهذه الاغتيالات اقول لك لا تؤثر
على نظام ولا تسقط نظام ولا تغير ملاع
معركه على الط محم
العران شريف حا اسمحلي محمد العران القائد
الميدني في كتيبه الله اكبر يعني هذه
العمليات يقول شريف شحاته لا قيمه لها
بدليل ان المواقع التي تهاجمون لا
تستطيعون السيطره عليها ولا وان المقياس
والمعيار لسيطرتهم هي ان تظلوا في هذه
المواقع على الاقل اشهر كما قال كيف
تردون ن من خلال عمليات القائمه على ض
الميدان المحافظه
الكامله
الخاصه محاصره حاجز
الم يبقى الا ثلاثه ايام مق الجيش الحر
وبعدها حاجز الجان وهذا الحاجز من اقوى
الحواجز الموجوده في المدينه وخلال
محاضرته
بقي ايام وسقط
ايضا وتابعنا حصار الدفاع الجوي الموجود
عند مبنى اذاعه في مدينه البوكمال وتاسع
يوم خط لك وخربوا جميع العناصر والضباط
و ومقتل بعضهم
و والكهرباء والان يقون جيش الشباب الجيش
الحرب
بحصار طيب على كل حال س سنحاول ان نقرا في
الجزء الثاني من هذه الحلقه المكاسب ان
كان هناك مكاسب للجيش السوري الحر
والمعارضه السوريه المسلحه بشكل عام من
هذه العمليات ولكن بعد هذا الفاصل فابقوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد لمناقشه الوضع
السوري على ضوء هذه الاستراتيجيه التي بدا
ينهجها الجيش السوري الحر والمعده المسلحه
في سوريا باستهداف مقرات امنيه وعسكريه
ومواقع عسكريه حساسه في سوريا ضيفنا
الدكتور اللواء الدكتور فايز الدويري
الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه
ان
اي تصل هذه المعاده المسلحه سواء كان ثوار
او الجيش السوري الحر الى ضرب اهداف كمطار
ابو الظهور مثلا وتدمير عدد من الطائرات
الرابض على ارضيته بل واستهداف ايضا مدرجه
من الناحيه
العسكريه ماذا تقرا انت في هذا الاستهداف
وما هي عوامل الت العوامل التي ساعدت هذه
القوات المعارضه للوصول الى اماكن حساسه
كهذه اخ عبد
الصمد انظر الى هذا هذه الاعمال من بعدين
البعد التخطيطي والبعد التنفيذي في في في
البعد التخطيطي يتضح ان هناك تحسن كبير
جدا في في البعد التخطيطي
لدى الجيش الحر ويتمثل هذا في تحديد ما
يعرف بالفك بالعلم العسكري على المستوى
الاستراتيجي تحديد مراكز الثقل والنقاط
الحاسمه والمناطق الحاسمه للعدو وهي يقصد
بها بتبسيط مراكز القوه الفاعله والضاره
لدى الخصب تتمثل مراكز القوى الرئيسيه في
القوه
الجويه وفي قطع طرق وطرق
الامداد وفي المراكز
الامنيه استطاع الجيش الحر ان يجمع ما
يسمى مبدئيا بنك معلومات للاهداف
الاستراتيجيه التي تضعف اداء وحدات النظام
تمثل ذلك بهجمات ناجحه على مطار تفتناز
وعلى مطار ابو الظهور وعلى مطار منج وتمثل
كذلك بمحاوله قطع شرايين الامداد القادمه
من اللاذقيه والقادمه من من حمص هذا تطور
نوعي في المستوى التخطيطي على المستوى
العملياتي والاستراتيجي ناتي الى البعد
التنفيذي او المستوى التكتيكي حقق نجاحات
دمر ع طائرات الان على شريط الاخبار اسقاط
ثلاث ثلاث طائرات اذا حقق الجيش الحر تميز
في ادائه التخطيطي والتنفيذي وهذا يقود
الى نقطه هامه جدا بدا الجيش الحر هو الذي
يتولى زمام المباداه والجيش النظامي لا
يملك زمام المباداه انما يتعقب اعمال
الجيش الحر ويتعامل مع هذه الاعمال في
الفكر الاستراتيجي الجيش الذي لا يملك
زمام المباداه سيخسر الحرب على المدى
الطويل مهاجم المقار الامنيه المقار
الامنيه لها دلالتها الرمزيه لدى الشعب
السوري هذه المراكز تمثل صوت الجلاد
تاريخيا وبالتالي احتلال مركز في دير
الزور يعني توجيه ضرب
الى النظام في البعد التخطيطي والبعد
التنفيذي
ن طيب اللواء يعني الجيش حينما يصل الى
هذه المراكز الحساسه كما تقول يفترض انه
له ربما فرق اصبحت الان مدربه ومؤهله
لتنفيذ هذ هذه العمليات النوعيه وايضا ان
لديه ربما اجهزه اتصالات متطوره جدا
واجهزه رصد للقوات النظاميه اليس
كذلك نعم لقد تم تزويد الجيش الحر باجهزه
اتصال مشفره وهذا تمت الافصاح عنه من من
قبل بعض المسؤولين الامريكيين تم الحصول
على بعض معدات وبعض الاسلحه التي تستخدم
من خلال حصولها عليها واستيلائها عليها من
الجيش النظامي هناك مر عليها اكثر من 12
شهر في عمليات قتاليه التحق به عدد من
الضباط برتب مختلفه وتاهيل متباين انضم
اليه جماعات اخرى وبالتالي اصبح لديه خبره
قتاليه من وبالتالي تحسن ادائه التنفيذي
على المستوى التكتيكي النقطه الاهم اخ عبد
الصمد ان القدره التخطيطيه في المستوى
العمليات هي النقطه المهمه جدا في هذا
البعد حيث اذا استمر بتحقيق هذه النجاحات
ووضع لديه بنك معلومات عن الاهداف
الاستراتيجيه فان ايام النظام بدا
تتراجع وبدات تقصر بشكل واضح فقط اعود الى
الخبر الذي ذكرته قبل قليل يعني عن عن
اسقاط ثلاث طائرات في ادلب سنحاول ان نعود
هذا الخبر بعد قليل ولكن اريد ان انقل هنا
فكره فكرتك الى ضيفنا في في طبعا هذه
الصوره الان وصلتنا
لاسقاط ثلاث طائرات في ادلب منها مروحيه
وا قد اعلنت عن ذلك كتائب شهداء سوريا عن
تبني هذه العمليه
شريف شحاده ضيفنا يقول بان نجاح المقاومه
او المعارضه المسلحه في اسقاط هذه
الطائرات وفي السيطره على مراكز امنيه
وعسكريه هو مؤشر على ضعف النظام وتخلله
وايضا على الارهاق الذي اصبح الان تعاني
منه المؤسسه العسكريه هناك عامل اخر يقول
بان هذه العمليات لم تكن لتنجح لولا ان
المعارضه المسلحه اخترقت النظام وهناك
عناصر من داخل النظام تساعد الجيش السوري
الحر على تنفيذ هذه العمليات ما
قولك اولا انا اريد ان اعلق على ضيفك من
الاردن اعتقد انه يعني قريب الى مشاهده
الافلام الهنديه من الواقع السوري واعتقد
انه يتحدث عن امنيات اكثر من واقع يا سيدي
اي جيش حر واي سيطره واي افلام يعني التي
نتحدث عنها هل ممكن ان يقول لي الان ضيفك
وين الجيش الحر مسيطر وفي اي محافظه وعن
يعني عن ماذا يتحدث يعني اذا تم اسقاط
طائره او طائرتين ونحن نعلم ان هناك اسلحه
تورد من تركيا الى الى هؤلاء المسلحين
الارهابيين عن اي اماكن يكون نحن في
العاصمه السوريه نعرف العاصمه السوريه
ونحن ندرك ما ذا الذي يحصل في حلب تحدثوا
في حلب عن انهم استطاعوا السيطره على قلعه
حلب ثم تحدثوا انهم استطاعوا السيطره على
نجاعه والتلفزيون ثم تحدثوا انهم استطاعوا
السيطره على كامل صلاح الدين حي صلاح
الدين ووجدنا بعد يوم او يومين انهم لم
يسيطروا حتى على عقول الناس واعتقد انكم
انتم بالدفع يعني من خلال هذا الاعلام
ترونهم اكثر وتذهبون بهم الى ان يصدقوا
الكذبه
التي
المشه دقيقه واحده
دقيقه واحده اي سيطره يا سيدي طيب طيب
الفكره وضحت يا استاذ استاذ شريف الفكره
لكن المشكله المشكله اعلاميا الصوره الان
التي يتابعها الناس ان اليش الحر يستهدف
مواقع عسكريه
ومواقع امنيه بينما الصوره ينقها الاعلام
ان الجيش النظامي يقتل عشرات بل مئات الان
بشكل يومي من
المدنيين يا استاذ انت تتحدث عن سيطره
الهجوم شيء والسيطره شيء اخر قد يكوم هلاء
المجموعات المسلحه بالهجوم على 100 مركز
لكن على اي مركز يسيطرون ممكن ان ترصد لي
وانت الان على قناه الجزيره كيك ولديك كل
الملفات عن سوريا ارصد لي عن اي محافظه
يسيطرون او على اي مركز امني او اي اي
شارع يعني انا اقول لك وجود مجموعات مسلحه
في هذا الشارع او ذاك الشارع لا يعني
السيطره السيطره في العلم العسكري ان
تسيطر على المكان سيطره تامه في الارض
والجو وكل الاماكن انا اعتقد ان لان الوقت
يكاد ينتهي دعني اترك الكلمه للدكتور لواء
الكتور فايز الدور لرد عليك في هذه النقطه
بالذات العسكري وانا لواء سابق لا يوجد في
العلم العسكري ان هناك مده زمنيه تحدد مدى
السيطره على اي هدف النقطه الاخرى هناك
معلومات رشحت من اكثر من جهه بان الجيش
الحر يسيطر سيطره جزئيه على 70 الى 80% من
الاراضي السوريه الخاصره اللينه من الحدود
من الحدود التركيه مرورا بمنبج الى حلب
وصولا الى حمص وحتى الحدود الغربيه الى
سهل الغاب لا يسيطر الجيش النظامي الا على
ما يسمى الحواجز وهذه الحواجز عباره عن
مواقع عسكريه تستخدم لاطلاق الصواريخ
والنيران في الواقع الجيش الحر يسيطر
جزئيا على معظم جغرافيه سوريا ومجرد
مهاجمه المقرات والمطارات يعني بان الجيش
النظامي يعاني من مشكلتين مشكله تخطيطيه
وهناك غياب مطبق للحلقات تخطيطيه اين وزير
الدفاع اين رئيس الاركان اين الايجاز
اليومي هناك ضبابيه مطلقه الجيش النظامي
يقاتل كوحدات منعزله دون خطه عمليات ودون
خطه استراتيجيه شكراك لواء الدكتور فايز
الدوير الخبير في شؤون العسكريه
واستراتيجيه من عمان شكرا جزيلا لك ونشكر
من البوك فيدر زور محمد العران القائد
الميداني في كتيبه الله اكبر التابعه
للجيش السوري الحر والذي للاسف لم يشاركنا
كثيرا لتقطع الصوت
وخلل فني منن دمشق شريف شحاده الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي شكرا لكم جميعا بهذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج مو الخبر غدا
بحول الله نقرا في مره خبر جديد شكرا لكم
الى اللقاء بحول
[موسيقى]
الله